[Music]  seventy years ago robert schuman laid  the foundations of the european union in  paris  he promised that on those foundations a  new europe would be built  it was a message of peace unity and hope  between neighbouring countries emerging  from the horrors and destruction of the  second world war  today we face our own challenge living  up to these ideals during the kovit 19  pandemic  workers across the continent are pulling  together keeping essential services open  member states are offering their  neighbours a helping hand to fight the  virus  and are continuing to build their common  future together  to fight a pandemic that knows no  borders european solidarity  is essential today's challenges echo  schuman's own vision of the european  health community  uniting national health strategies and  medical research  to face common health threats as a union  you